The Fast Saga might be coming to a close - but
the next flick in the main series still might
not be the last.
In keeping with the franchise's "more is more"
aesthetic, star Vin Diesel has suggested that
Fast 10 might be split into two parts.
He made his remarks in a recent, wide-ranging
interview with Total Film magazine.
The bombshell about the final Fast flick came
as Diesel was discussing possibilities for
the future of the franchise, which he hopes
will extend long beyond the life of the main
series in the form of spin-offs.
Of course, the first of these - Fast and Furious
Presents: Hobbs & Shaw - hit theaters last
summer, pleasing the heck out of audiences
and cleaning up at the box office to the tune
of $760 million worldwide.
No doubt, fans were shouting, "Make more!"
"No one tells me what to do!"
Anyway, Diesel said:
"The universe is so robust and so rich with
talent and rich with story that, on one level,
it's totally feasible to have spinoffs, and
I think that's something that is inevitable.
[Studio] Universal deserves it because of
how much they've invested in this little saga,
and it'd be good to give back to Universal.
And for the fans, should Fast 10 parts one
and two be the conclusion, it would be nice
for this world to continue for generations
to come."
Generally speaking, two-part conclusions are
more commonly associated with film adaptations
of popular books - and since none but the
final volume in each series ever seems to
require the two-part treatment, the strategy
can be seen as something of a cash grab.
Perhaps the most famous example is Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows, a novel which dedicates
an absurd amount of its length to characters
wandering around in the woods, and which it
could be argued really didn't need a pair
of two-hour films to tell its story.
More recently, The Hunger Games: Mockingjay
was split into two parts, which doesn't seem
quite so egregious; the novel is slightly
more narratively dense, and as there are only
three books in the series, it's understandable
that the movies' producers would seek to give
audiences more to chew on.
Strangely, though, in the case of Potter,
the strategy paid off - but for Hunger Games,
not so much.
Deathly Hallows Part 2 was by far the highest-grossing
film in the series, with Part 1 coming in
third behind Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone; by contrast, Mockingjay Part 2 was
actually the series' lowest-grossing entry,
with Part 1 coming in second behind Catching
Fire.
Of course, Hunger Games wasn't quite the box
office force that Potter was, so the not-so-surprising
takeaway here is that the greater your franchise's
cultural reach, the more likely it is that
audiences will shell out for two tickets to
see the conclusion of the story.
With a worldwide gross of nearly $6 billion
and the two most recent entries in the main
series having cleared $1 billion globally,
the Fast franchise is one for which the strategy
could pay off, big time.
Obviously, box office numbers like that tend
to prompt studios to look for ways to extend
franchises for as long as possible, which
brings us to those spin-offs.
Hobbs & Shaw is, for the time being, the #4
all-time earner in the series, behind only
Fast and Furious 6, The Fate of the Furious,
and Furious 7.
Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson is a top box office
draw, his co-star Jason Statham looks ready
to keep kicking ass forever, and the two have
excellent onscreen chemistry; it wouldn't
surprise us at all if Hobbs & Shaw were to
become its own franchise, and while no sequel
has yet been confirmed, the flick's three
post-credits scenes sure seemed to be setting
one up.
Here's what has been confirmed: According
to Entertainment Weekly, an as-yet untitled,
all-female spin-off is likely to center on
Michelle Rodriguez' Letty.
Diesel himself has talked up the project,
and it's currently being scripted by Guardians
of the Galaxy writer Nicole Perlman, Lindsey
Beer - who's currently working on the upcoming
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles reboot - and
Geneva Robertson-Dworet, who penned Captain
Marvel.
With a wealth of great characters to choose
from, the Fast universe could spin off in
untold directions once the main series comes
to a close; heck, those spin-offs might even
introduce new characters which could receive
spin-offs of their own in the future.
As long as it keeps bringing the high-octane
action, fans will keep lining up for the latest
installment - and, speaking of which, you
may want to mark your calendar.
F9 comes roaring into theaters on May 22,
2020.
"There's nothing more powerful than the love
of family.
You turn that into anger - there's nothing
more dangerous."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.